and we can now confirm that the home  office has told Sky News sowella  Braverman has gone as Home Secretary one  of the big three beasts in Liz truss's  government out this afternoon after in  one of the most perilous positions  leaving Liz trust in one of the most  perilous of political positions we don't  yet have a full readout of the reasons  but it comes on a deadly day for Liz  truss as she struggles to main her  Authority clearly amongst her cabinet  certainly amongst her own MPS with whom  she's picking a fight this afternoon and  now one of the biggest figures in her  cabinet who has leadership Ambitions is  now out and on the outside she will only  continue to build her profile you just  mentioned Sarah Jane some of the things  that Sue Ella Braverman has been doing  in that short period in office